also analyzed a little bit of the
sharing economy this would be a tag team
approach so I'll start for the first 45
minutes or so and then my colleague
anestachio snowless will do the second
part we'll switch over so you can get
the slides and not code in in the github
over there I'm gonna cover a bunch of
stuff so it's gonna be relatively quick
you it will help if you want to follow
along it will help if you have the the
Twitter shapely shape file URL bars
Foursquare request beautifulsoup
and also network its installed just in
case you want follow along if not I'll
try just and describe more or less what
you what will would be doing and how
it's going to work and work so you're
all familiar with Twitter as you know
tweet unlimited 140 characters this does
not mean that we cannot squeeze a lot of
information into them and that you
cannot get a lot of information and in
particular most of the interesting stuff
is actually not in the tweet itself but
in the metadata that's associated to the
tweet right so here we have an example
we have the author of the tweet in case
it's me we can have hashtags you can
have URLs you can see who retweeted it
how many times will retweet it so you
can observe how the tweet is spreading
through the network you can see one and
you can even see where so can have
geolocation information which of course
is what we're interested in here when
you actually connect to the API even and
you're going to see that in a second
what you get back is basically a big
dictionary look with a bunch of keys
that has a huge amount of information
right so for for a twitter can be at
most 140 characters the the full tweet
object the that you read that the API
returns to you is can be up to three or
four K so it's a lot more information
right and in particularly you have in a
lot of information about the user so
their username even their profile
background image that the colors on the
website you know everything about the
user notice anything that Twitter knows
you of course also have the the text of
the tweet you have the source and this
is the application that was used to
generate the tweet so was it the the web
interface was it the mobile interface
what was at Foursquare so in this case
it was Foursquare for example you have
entities which is another dictionary
object the basically lists where you
were inside the tweet you can find the
hashtags
how they are structured where they
yes hashtags user mentioned symbols URLs
etc and of course you can have it the
Geo clothing information you can have
coordinate you can have coordinates and
there's also this in from the geo field
now is actually being deprecated and
being replaced by coordinates field that
just lists the coordinates directly so
before we can actually do anything with
Twitter you actually have to create an
account after you have an account you
have to register an application all
right so did you have to go to she-devil
well there to app store calm and you get
something like this and you can create a
new app you need to fill in a few a few
fields so the name of the app a little
description a website and this is going
to be important so this is working from
in principle you where information about
your application would be would be found
and then a callback URL which is where
the after your user authenticates with
the application where it's going to be
redirected to of course you have to
accept the rules of the road and not
read them and just press yes which is
what everybody does and in the end what
you're going to get you're going to see
something like this those going to list
who can they give you the API key which
I'm covering there for privacy reasons
and the API secret as well and then you
have to generate the token right and and
to actually be able to do anything with
the application you're going to need
both the API key the API secret the
token key in the token secret so it's
gonna be four magic numbers that you're
going to use and this is what you're
gonna have to pass to the API to achieve
yeah go to authenticate download tweets
post tweets delete tweets do everything
you could possibly do so assuming you
all have all of this setup we can move
on a little bit so the API basics just
to give you an idea of how do the
Twitter module from the Twitter for the
Twitter library basically gives you the
basic interface the way the the library
and module is structured mimics very
closely the Y D API its office structure
so it's very easy it is always best to
keep your conditions inside the dict so
I can easily switch between account if
you have multiple sets of credentials
what I do to thought of basic attacks
and no earth instance
as an argument and then retweets it
returns to your Twitter object then you
can then use to do all the operations
Twitter member the methods basically
meet API structure and there's no
missing one over there there's three
types of objects have tweets you have
users who have and you have entities
which other things are mostly interested
in so just a quick example to see how it
actually works in the if you're
following along with the github
repository this is the name of the file
the taxi has this code so the file names
always appear over there and they'll
always be inside the the github
repository inside the directory called
part one because then they'll attack is
we want to understand use so the idea is
very simple like I said you have I have
a dictionary with the name that was just
a representation of of the set of
credentials and associated inside this
name there is another dictionary with
which recipe ikeda classic with the
token and token secret of course you
have to replace here it says API key set
with the actual magic numbers that you
get from the Twitter website and then
it's very simple you just select the
country only use and you pass the
information to the awards object to do
was method and then that returns an
object that you can use to authenticate
with a Twitter directly right and if all
goes well and nothing in the world
doesn't explode now you have a Twitter
API or whatever called Twitter API
object that you can then you that you
can use for everything else so far so
good no questions yes I'm sorry
yes let me go back yes
here is the github sorry oops
so if you go to github.com under my my
account Bianchi concave as if I'm my
name's your reference data sorry if I'm
going fine too quickly yeah yes this
basically the way this works is it it's
like as if you are using your own
account to do things so in that limits
also what you're in some cases can limit
what you're able to see like if
something if I have a private account
and which means that only people who Y
authorize are following me and you try
to access my account using the API and
you don't follow me so I never
authorized you can't see it but if you
do follow me then you can see it so it's
almost like you're creating an agent a
software agent that's doing things for
you so it's a cool way of thinking about
it so far so good excellent
now let's jump forward to where we were
so so this is the basic structure of how
you authenticate right you need the four
the four magic numbers that you can
always put in this order and if you have
basically a dictionary with different
account doses each with different names
and you just want to switch between
accounts it's very simple you just
switch the name you you access from the
dictionary there and everything else
works the same so now how do you search
for tweets right so you finally identica
it you did all the things now you won't
actually get data so you want to search
for tweets and in particularly on the
search for two it's referring to some
specific keyword let's say so and the
way you do this is using the method dot
search dot tweets okay searching for
tweet and you can see that it matches
basically the exactly the structure of
the API documentation so it's it's a get
method search and then tweet so you get
dots or tweet
and this means that you're doing the
using this tutor a P I object so did
Twitter API dot searches or tweets then
what they require you want and then
count is how many results you want to
return per page the maximum number is
two hundred and if the if there is more
results after that basically have to
lock up D the URL to use to get the next
page of results and you can go back and
back into the past like this the way the
search works is it basically starts
searching now and back in the direction
of the past it's limited to I believe
the maximum of seven days so you cannot
go further back than seven days ago and
and after you start searching it it will
not update with future results you'll
just only go back in the past so to see
this how it actually works in practice
and now that the file you should be
looking at this search Twitter search
underscore Twitter dot pi the the
beginning of the other script is always
the same I'm just selecting the right
account authenticating so I I try to
make each script completely
self-contained so that you can use it
doesn't just if you just want to search
for tweets you can just replace the
query there and this will just search
for them directly and you don't have to
change anything else of course you need
your own credentials and and I should
have mentioned that
I'm keeping basically all the account
information in in this video file called
Twitter accounts and that way I don't
have to worry about showing you my
credentials directly and you can just
update that file with your own
credentials so well true just means keep
going into there's no no more result
searching for the next result and if
there's no more results you can use a
stop so whenever there's an error it
just break out and here what this will
give you is just basically a list with
with all the tweets that it found and in
this case we're using force so we're
searching for tweets that mention
Foursquare for some reason in them we're
looking for to get at most two hundred
which is the maximum that you can get by
default I believe it's twenty five so
you want to get two hundred to get as
many results as possible
does this make sense so far
excellent so of course searching into
the past is not always what you want to
do most of the time and the most
interesting thing you can do is actually
stream data and what this means is
you're tapping to into Twitter and you
get a real-time stream of what's
happening in the world around the world
is seen through Twitter its SodaStream
for this you need the streamer the
streaming API this is slightly different
than the normal API we just used this
gives you of course real-time data would
subject to filters and then of course
you can filter based on different things
in this case instead generating a
Twitter object you generate a Twitter
stream object so you the da Twitter
stream us and then the Twitter API over
there
and then to filter you you give it a
query under the keyword track and this
will return to its that match the query
queue in real time so if we did the same
thing we did before
search for for for Foursquare instead of
sending of showing you tweets mentioning
Foursquare going back into the past you
will start now and keep updating you
every time a new tweet at Foursquare
camp of course this is limited to API
rate limitations and how much how much
filter is willing to give you but
basically after you do this what you get
is a generator that you can just iterate
over and get more tweets so let's look
at yes so you can also search for user
user profiles so if you want if you want
to know more about the user - and you
can get more information about the user
so here we're looking for two for two
users big uncovers a notice the way it
works now is that the the keyword that
you using it and what you're searching
for is basically a comma-separated list
of screen names so in this case big
uncovers and you know that you do api
users lock up and that's the
documentation the twitter documentation
for users lock up again you can see that
the structure is exactly the same so it
makes it very easy and you just say okay
I'm looking for screen names and give it
screen names you can also do this with
user IDs these are the internal
numerical IDs the Twitter users and you
can give them just a again Thomas
separated list of user IDs and you
work the same way but here instead of
saying screen names you use you use user
ID equal comma separated list of user
IDs and then what you get basically is
the same thing so you get an iterator
and then you you iterate over them and
you said this use and here I'm just
putting a little statistic and say this
username has this many followers that's
it you can also look for for social
connections so Fred you can look for the
friends and the followers of a user here
I'm going a little bit faster because
it's not the main topic but it's
interesting to know you can get the user
the friends IDs and user IDs this these
methods are particularly interesting
because you can get up to 5,000 user IDs
very quickly so you won't give you any
information about those users you just
give it the numeric IDs of those users
all right so if you just want to know
who this user is following you can do
this very quickly 5,000 seems like a big
number but when you think that many many
users you're interested in have millions
and millions of followers this these
five thousand are not that many when you
think about it and what this gives you
back is a dictionary with a few fields
it gives you the next cursor string the
previous cursor and so the nectar
searching is basically how you get the
next page of result if they use if the
user you're you're querying
has more than 5,000 followers or friends
the IDS is basically the list of is
basically the list of followers or
friends depending on which part you're
querying in that and the results an X
cursor just gives you the next page of
results and you can just ask for the
next page basically by doing this you
you query again the same thing and now
you give it a cursor with the results
next cursor which is what information
you get from there
and if cursor is zero means that there's
no more results left questions so a
simple example and how you do this so
again you do it the authentication now
we're looking for Stephen Wolfram start
to cursor minus one means start at the
beginning
I'm looking for followers asking for
followers of this green name starting
with cursor here means -1 and what the
cursor is not 0 so when the cursor is 0
it ends and this is just giving me
updating a list without and without the
follower IDs you say forget how many
followers this gives you but it gives
you a lot also interesting especially
when you you find users that you for
instance you you're trying to find users
that have geolocation information
because that's what we've been the focus
in this in a second and you're trying to
see where these does have been so we're
trying to to follow the users over time
right one thing is very interesting you
ask for their timeline and what the
timeline is is risky the list of all the
tweets that that person has ever posted
now here there is a limit to 3,200
tweets Twitter will never not let you go
further back than that if the user has
for example five thousand tweets it will
give you the last 30 202 it's you know
not go below that you can sometimes get
less than 3200 if the user for example
deleted tweet and then you get a few
less but the maximum you ever get is
3200 the way it works is exactly the
same so again now we have statuses user
time 9 because we statuses is how
Twitter refers eternity internally to
tweet so asking for statuses gives a
timeline basically means a timeline of a
specific user include retweets true
means do you want to see what the user
retweeted as as well or only what user
posted directly of course if you if you
put include retweets false you will get
less tweets because you would just shut
her out all the retweet count again 200
is the number of tweets you want to
return in each call the 200 is again the
maximum dream user true means you do not
want to receive the user object with
every tweet that you post because it's
always the same user so it's all the
same object so you're not interesting
that you can just say no you can just
say dream user equals true and I would
not include that information and that
basically saves you bandwidth and max in
my maximum ID is basically you can limit
what is the the maximum tweet I do you
want to see and this is how you you go
back in time look when you go back in
the timeline this will return the most
200 you snitch
and you can get all the user treats up
to 3200 and only up to max max ID so you
can see this in practice here so again
we're just logging in now we're looking
for me you want two hundred tweets 3ms
are true because we don't care about
these information and you want three
tweets true so this is a way of
basically sub supplying all the
arguments directly to the API calls just
to start start arcs and that will just
unfold this and it's the same as having
count equals two hundred three misery
goes through etcetera just for that and
then you start with a list and you just
keep adding stuff to the list basically
currently yes yes it I forgot to put the
folder where it should be there yes
unless I forgot to commit it but I think
it should either yes and of course since
you're getting all that all the Twitter
user or the other tweets posted by user
you can also see who this user in is
interacting with right so you can see
who is mentioning and who is retweeting
and this of course is only true if you
include retweets again you're doing the
same thing you're searching for getting
the user timeline tweets new coz tweets
and you're doing the same thing but now
afterwards you just go over all the
tweet and if it's a retweet you
basically see who that user retweeted
who is the other user that was retweeted
and if it's a reply you can see who it
was replied to so I can see basically
the interactions of these users you can
see who this user is talking to knew who
this user is retweeting which gives you
an idea of gives an idea basically on
what is the social structure the social
activity of this specific user which can
be interesting in many contexts so but
okay so this is how you you look
specifically for a user I already show
you how to stream data in general but
now what we want actually is out to
stream do locate the date because that's
the most interesting thing right so
stream API yes
yes so this is a sabbatical this is
again how you string the data this is
just an example you're quoting for
Justin Bieber because Bieber is a people
are always talking about Bieber so
that's the example I always use because
there's always stuff happening so I
never just running out not get any
result and here what I'm doing is
basically for the for the results I'm
getting and basically printing just the
text of the tweet so you if you run this
you'll just see a long stream of text
coming up in the real time and this is
what people are saying about Bieber now
if you want to specifically look at your
located data then you want to see ok the
streaming API again will give you your
own data subject to filters you do the
same thing so it's exactly what you just
said a few minutes ago but now what you
want to do is you wanna filter by
location right and so to do that the the
keyword you to use is locations and then
you have to give it a bounding box the
bounding box is basically the set of of
latitude longitude coordinates basically
found defines a box of results very
interested in so this for example if you
give at minus 180 minus 90 180 90 will
give you the world because you're
defining them the minimum likely to the
minimum longitudinal maximum maximum
logical you're interested in or if
you're just interested in in New York
City
you can just give it - 74 40-73 41 one
thing you you'll notice here is the
convention so it's longitude latitude
and you can think of this basically is
being XY coordinate so if you think of
it in terms of a plot so which is the
exact opposite of what you'd use
normally as you normally say latitude
longitude and not longitude latitude so
you have to be careful that many times
you eat you get in trouble basically by
switching the numbers and then nothing
matches now if you do that then you just
again I'm gonna do exactly the same
thing authenticate this is the query
we're looking for just looking for New
York City minused stream result so now
I'm giving it a location equals that
query so I'm on tweets happening or
referring to this area here
I'm just counting them and now I'm just
gonna store them in a in the file in a
zipped file
so for each tweet I get I update my
account I look at the tweet ID and I
just printing the tweet ID and then I'm
storing the tweet inside that file and
then after a thousand and basically
basically quitting so this is just we
just generate a few tweets store them in
the file right and actually if you look
in the repository you'll find this file
and this I ran this last Sunday I guess
up to ten thousand so just to give you a
few tweets you can do that you can look
at so of course yes yes yes for the user
that is for the user timeline here you
do not have the limit for three thirty
two hundred right here in prison you
will get all the tweets well you will
get a never ending number of tweets
let's put it away now depending on what
access level you have you can get you'll
get more or less in general if you do
nothing you just create an account today
and register an application what what
they give you is the basic access which
is one percent it corresponds roughly to
one percent and what this means is you
get roughly one percent of all the
tweets so they're just sample down you
cannot be sure if it's random I
reasonably sure it's random I've never
seen anything that's showing that it's
too biased one way or the other but so
you can more or less assume that for
every tweet at anybody posts you have
one percent chance of getting that tweet
it's not exactly like that's with of
course you can also buy higher access
you can get the DECA hoes for example
and that gives you ten percent of all
the tweets or you can get the firehose
and you get everything but those become
very expensive very quickly like tens of
thousands of dollars a month expensive
so and this will give you a bunch of
tweets in real time restrict it to this
location this is just a little simple
script I wrote just to plot them just to
see where the tweets are so we were
searching for tweets inside New York
City within that fandom
box you will remember yes
so the money box is between - 74 42
minus 73 41 so it's basically one degree
by one degree this will just basically
open that file extract the tweet look
for the coordinate and then just plot it
using matplotlib mumbai plot so just the
simplest thing you can you can do and I
use that just to basically generate this
figure right what one interesting thing
you look about you'll notice about this
figure is the range right the range is
much much larger than what you expected
right you asked for a one degree area
somewhere around there and you got a
bunch of stuff everywhere else and the
reason for that is because Twitter is a
bit sneaky about how it selects which
tweets to give you now you say we want
tweets referring to this bounding box
that does not mean that it will give you
only tweets that happen inside that
bounding box you also give you tweets
that somehow refer to that bounding box
which is a bit strange if you think
about it so these are the tweets that
actually have GPS coordinates so these
are the one these are the actual
coordinates that are associated with
that but for instance if like I do in
your profile you mentioned you live
inside New York's you live in New York
City in your location field and you post
a tweet with GPS coordinates Twitter
might might give that to it as well
because it thinks that might be
interesting to you even though I'm not
necessarily when I'm when I'm tweeting
in Portugal for example I'm not inside
New York City but you will still show up
there so you would see a dot somewhere
over there saying that guys in New York
City right so you get a bit messy here
yes back there
these are all all GPS okay now the
reason why Twitter selected these guys
over here for example was not because
the GPS was inside that bounding box but
because there was other information in
the tweets that refer to that bounding
box so Twitter is more generous about
the way it does right yes that's exactly
the next step good job I should pay you
I should pay you a coffee later now how
do we filter this out right now the way
you you define geographical boundaries
in general is use shapefiles
right you can actually go to that
website of the new york city government
and download the official shapefile that
gives you the boundaries of the outer
boroughs of New York City right and it
looks something like this and it
basically defines everything the
official definition of what New York
City is yes this of unfortunately
they're not using the right projection
they're using a different projection
what we want is the what we call here
the wgs84 yes wgs84 which basically
latitude and longitude defining defined
on the on the space on the grid defined
in 1984 that defines basically what
lights do not do this around the world
you can convert it here I'm just this is
very simple exercise you just open it in
your favorite GIS program and then you
just save it as and you change the
coordinate system before you save it and
that would just generate another file
with the right coordinate to save you
the trouble I downloaded the original
files I converted them and you can find
them all in there yes
yes I'm not very familiar with them the
tangled eggs is like OG RTR yes
QGIS and you can and it's open source
and you can use it for everything of
course the official one is ArcGIS which
is extremely expensive and only
available in Windows QGIS does like 95%
of everything you could ever want and
it's much much more lightweight but in
any case for this example you have all
the files you need there
there is no files are called NY BB
underscore 15 C I think and or an or
just NY BB and then the ones with the
modified coordinates are and why BB
underscore wgs84 something so you can
see that the distinction easily now if
you have this and what you have is
basically an arbitrary polygon that
defines the area you're interested in
there's a little a great old pie shape
or a pie shape file on the paper defined
utility functions to load and manipulate
shape files programmatically yes do you
have a little bit of time so the only
thing you really need to know about this
is how to read the file and how to get
the records it basically tells you what
are what are the the polygons that are
defined and the shapes is basically
gives you all the shape all the shape
information you need and before you can
use that you need another library called
shapely and shapely basically gives you
a way of defining geometric object and
simple operations on these geometric
objects right so it can define points
polygons Multi polygons shape that is a
very simple way which is when can you
use to basically generate the right
polygon based on information that you
get from other places
and you can talk it can give you a very
simple way of calculating other things
it can calculate what is the centroid of
a polygon if one polygon crosses another
one if it's inside another one that's it
it's within another one if it touches
another one off and there's many many
many many more here are just a few of
them so how do we actually do this this
is just an example of how to actually
load the shapefile so again so you just
open it there you see you found
records then you just go over all the
records and you should not show the name
so this would be this is a real simple
example so if you run this on the
shapefile I gave you you list basically
Staten Island Brooklyn Bronx Manhattan
yes and then you let you select one so
here I will just unit the command line
and then you just select the one you
want and say if if you didn't find it
you didn't find it and if it found that
he says okay I'm going to use that one
and then calculates the here I was going
to select Manhattan and then I was just
going to check that the centroid of
manhattoes inside Manhattan just to
should exemplify how you can do this
right now you can also use that to
actually filter to its directly so
looking again on the file here again I'm
going to use the file I just used before
that I just gave you of the NYC tweet
here I'm opening the shapefile directly
so I said NY be be underscore wgs84
which is the modified one again it way
to fund find five records I'm gonna
select two which corresponds Manhattan
here gonna print the list of Records
again and you say okay when you use
Manhattan select Manhattan and then open
another file and then for each tweet in
the in the New York City file it will
check if it's inside Manhattan or not
and if it and if it is it was closed
over to the Manhattan file right and if
you do this what after you run this
you'll get another file called Manhattan
dot JSON dot J Z which is already in
there and if you plot it you get exactly
what you would expect you get only
coordinates inside Manhattan now what so
so far what you have is you have a way
of searching Twitter finding the Twitter
interested in filtering even by location
I should have mentioned that internally
mentioned that if you search for a
specific query and you search for a
location it doesn't actually do d the
end of the two it gives the D or so will
give you things that match either the
query or the location you cannot do both
you have to do two steps if you wanted
if you wanna do both so you could search
for a specific query like forth
Justin Bieber and then filter out the
ones you inside the location or search
for a location and then filter out the
topics you want by hand but you can do
both at the same time
because I'll just give you the are of
all the filters you apply and here you
can see that the coordinates are of
course are are correct and you can
basically recognize the map of Manhattan
so and this basically gives you a big
overview of what you can do with Twitter
and how you you can get geolocate to
Twitter data process it in analyze and
extract what you want right now another
big source of geolocation data is
Foursquare Foursquare of course is a
check-in it's a way for you to advertise
your check-ins so you say ok I'm in this
location right now which of course
started more or less within within
Twitter the Twitter ecosystem and then
branched out what you generate with
Foursquare are basically check-ins
so you say this user checked in at this
place again you can have a little to
basically what corresponds to a tweet
you can see how many people liked it you
can have of course URL associated with
it etc again when you connect to the API
you get an object with a bunch of
information a lot less information than
in a tweet well that's ok when you
basically gives information about the
place where the check-in is occurring
entities I get again gives the
information about URLs etc that are
inside not the text of the check-in is
called a shout and that's just the text
and the likes basically tells you how
many people liked it he does not give
you information about you who liked it
again if you wanna do something you have
to actually create the Foursquare
account you have to register an
application and this would generate
again the magic numbers here it's a
little bit trickier you actually have to
give it a redirect URI so this is where
it's going to redirect you after you
login to the applique what what your
user would be redirected to us early
login with your application and this
actually has to work that URL that has
to exist exist in some for in some
fashion but it's going to use it in a
second
due to to actually register the
application it's a little bit a bit
trickier than it was before so now you
have the client ID in the client secret
that you'd basically get from here very
easily just by clicking register an
application filling out a couple of
fields and in this form which are
basically URLs and a little bit of
Ephraim and the name of the application
you're using or rather that you are
creating so now they'll give you the
client ID in a client secret which are
two of the tokens you'll need but now
you need you need the actual token that
you're gonna use to do everything so the
way to do this is first you need to
request the North URL which is basically
the URL which you connect which you're
going to supply to your user and say ok
login now and and then the user will log
in there of course you don't want to
actually do that you want to do it
automatically so you using the client ID
and the client secret you can not enter
Kate with with the API you can ask for
an authorization URL and that gives you
a URL and the as before I'm going to put
all of basically this dictionary inside
the Foursquare accounts the Python file
and you know and again the all this code
is inside the auth URI for square now if
you try if you open the URL it's giving
you an actual browser you're gonna get
something like this and you say are you
are you okay authorizing this
application to access your account and
then you press ok and that will redirect
you to the URL that you selected in the
beginning when you are registering the
application right here
of course the URL doesn't actually have
to exist but something has to be there
and it's going to give you a big magic
number
hiding in the URL over there which is
hiding between the between the Eco sign
and the sharp sign right so it's all
that part that's selected over there and
this is the last piece of the of the
puzzle right after you have this with
this magic number there you can ask for
an access token and your need to do this
once and after you have the client code
the client token and the access token
you have everything now the reason why
here
you need three three pieces of
information for tutoring you the four
pieces of information is basically
because Twitter is using OS one here
using OAuth 2 which are different and
can be used for different things and
have different different trade-offs one
of the advantages of os/2 is just with
the access token you can do everything
that's all you need in the end most of
the time and the advantage of this is
that this token is basically given to
the application by the user and the user
can revoke it you can revoke it at any
time you can even assign expiration
dates on an access token so that they go
away automatically etcetera so it should
read if you're interested in that type
of stuff you should really read up on
the worth one and OAuth 2 because
they're very interesting now to actually
authenticate with the API you can do it
will exactly the same thing similar
thing to before you select the account
information again the account is inside
dictionaries inside the Foursquare
accounts there you you provide the
client ID and client secret you clay
you set the client token and then you
can start searching and using Foursquare
to extract information questions
so someone raised their hands this is
much simple and intuitive so less prone
to mistakes and it automatically takes
care of all the details right you can
just do what do this very easily now
there are two main types of objects you
have users in the venues and there so
people and places so think about it and
there's many things you can do that
users can do one venues they can check
in they can like and leave tips all
right so they say it like in this place
you should try the steak it's very good
now because of API limitations in the
beginning there were a lot more more
generous then they stopped being so
generous so they limited it a little bit
and the reason for this is because of
privacy concerns and they were very
generous and then people came up with
stalker apps with please drop me and say
okay look this user is not at all
so you should advertising that type of
thing and so they changed the API to to
reflect this so what what this means is
that it's very easy to get information
on users end on venues but it's very
hard to say this users in this venue
right
trying to keep the two things separate
so venues of course correspond to
physical locations they perhaps they're
the most object important object in the
Foursquare universe they are very
generous they give you 5,000 requests
per hour which is a lot you if you do
the the client object dot venues with
the venue ID will give you a new object
which again has a bunch of information
you can even get tips that were left on
the venue you can see who is there now
or at least some information about who
is there now venue similar will give you
a list of similar attractions as defined
by Foursquare and the similar the way
they define similarity is not always
clear when you search means that you can
locate you can search for places near
locations so you can search for pizza
near Times Square you'll give a list of
pizza places near Times Square so this
is an example on how to find some
similar venues so again you just do in
the authentication thing so to hear
exactly the same thing then this is the
venue idea I'm looking at I'm looking
and we look and I'm using the client
object to access the venue so I give it
a venue ID and that gives me the venue
information and here I'm looking for
similar venues so I'm saying okay with
this a new ID give me similar venues now
gives you a list of similar venues and
and here I'm just asking for the venue
object just to get information little
bit of information about the venue
because that looks like a magic number
and if you're if you run this you say
okay similar venues to this one are and
here's a list of them I think that then
you have member correctly it's like the
Empire State Building and of course if
you're if you can just run the the
script and see it in real time
now tips users can leave tips in venues
at any time this means that they don't
need to check in you can leave a tip on
Mount Everest right now even though not
a month Everest reduce steps for when
you can be accessed use via steps so
reduce tips means that they don't give
you the entirety of object they just
give you a limited set of information
this is a limit to a maximum of 500 per
call so you want to what you get from
here is at maximum 500
if there are more tips associated with
that menu then you can use the camp
parameter and and the offset to
basically go through the list and get
more information the four tip objects
can be obtained using the tips in
interface directly and you can get the
documentation over there and this
contains reduced user objects that are
public and basically give you a simple
way to connect users to venues but with
some limitations as I mentioned already
so this is how you actually use it so
this is the tips for squared dot pi
script again you're just authenticating
over there
this is the vanu ID now we're asking for
tips this gives you the list of tips and
how many tips there are and I keep
looking for more tips as long as there
are tips to look for and bring and
adding them all to the list and then
picking them all out basically it's a
very very simple code just to highlight
how you can do this now I'm almost done
with my part so check-ins check-ins of
course are the most important thing in
on Foursquare they're the reason why
Foursquare exists is to allow you to
check into a place it's a way of
connecting users with venues and give
you variable template demographic
information and this is basically the
information that I'm assuming Foursquare
sells to the today to their customers
don't check in to the check-in Eddie
will give you the check-in object if you
use the users interface to look for
check-ins with the user ID this will
give you all the check of the public
check-ins for that specific user of
course in many cases there won't be that
many public check-ins because of privacy
concerns as I mentioned or for all
check-ins if user ID is a friend is a is
your friend right so this goes back to
the same thing with Twitter
it looks at who you are and the person
that's authenticating you and that's why
I need the user information that's all
so you need an actual account on
Foursquare and not just an API account
so the way it works is the same way you
authenticate using ID and now you use
the check-ins interface to get
information you can also get information
about the user and you can see if I
remember correctly this checking ID was
done by Barack Obama
like one of the the public check-ins I
was able to find some time ago so of
course everybody wants privacy but not
too much privacy and particular people
like to show off and basically tell
their friends where they are so
Foursquare somehow had to increase the
privacy but also decrease the privacy
which is kind of weird so the way it
works is users can have the options of
sharing the their check-ins through
Twitter or Facebook right so yeah I can
check in on the place on Foursquare I'm
very clean self-conscious about my
privacy so I don't allow anyone on
Foursquare other than my friends to see
it but then I polish it on Twitter and
everybody can see it the start of text
is shared along with the URL to a web
version of the check-in since to
actually be able to pass through the the
privacy barrier you actually need the
access token but you don't want to give
you access an access token to everyone
so you create a new special access token
that only works for this specific
check-in and this is called the
signature and each signature is now it
just for that check-in for that user and
now so it's a single use token so this
is what a check-in URL looks like when
it's published on Twitter or on Facebook
so it's basically Foursquare calm or
swarm up now or whatever the user ID
check in the checking ID and then the
signature information there so something
like this so this is correspond to the
user g-iii yeah I guess performing this
check-in and has this signature so if
you use the check-ins interface with a
checking ID and give it the signature as
as a parameter to the function then
basically you can get to from it you can
access that page and actually see what
the check-in is right of course to do
that you actually need to be able to get
these URLs and the way you get is URL is
through Twitter so you search for
Foursquare research for you search for
geolocation okay to tweet inside those
you find the ones that have active
Foursquare information and then you just
need to extract that information from
there right so this is how you would
parse a URL so
this is the URL which I just showed you
in the previous slide you can you can
parse it using URL parse extract the
check-in ID which corresponds to the
base name the query will basically give
you what the signature is and then the
screen name is hiding inside the path
that you get and using that you can just
get the check-in directly I mean that's
magic and potentially against the Terms
of Service of Foursquare
depending on who you ask yes no this is
now this token is basically a token that
generation led by the user when they
check into a place and say okay I'm
allowing anyone that has that has this
token to see this dis checking right
they're not connected to you in any way
now the problem with doing this is you
are still going through the API which
means that you still have Audio API
limitations and you stay limited to X
number of check-ins etc the way to do
that is not go through the API at all
and basically go through the web
interface which again might be against
Terms of Service so you open so use the
request library to open the URL that you
just got from from Twitter using of you
can if you want to authenticate using
user and pass but that's just generic
information Ray's Gandhi syndication
this is Janaki freshen about the
requests requests who returned after you
connected to a URL you open the URL you
can return you a bunch of information
about the connection it's gonna say with
the status code okay did it was it able
to connect and obtain the page so is the
status code 200 or not the text is
basically the HTML the URL gives you the
final URL so if you have a URL shortener
this would be the end the complete and
shortened URL even if you have multiple
URL shorteners it would just navigate
through all the shorteners until it gets
to a final page and I'll give you the
fresh and now Jason if the document on
the other side is Jason this will just
give you the JSON object directly so
this is an example on how you don't
think you could use this in general to
authenticate which is not particularly
interesting here but it seemed important
because it
highlights the idea that you can provide
headers and these headers can are away
basically of you providing extra
information to the two minutes provide X
information to the server so that it can
handle your requests better in
particular since you're you're trying to
get around all of these limitations you
can use this to spoof your user agent so
instead of instead of the server looking
at the request and saying oh this is
coming from Python you can say you can
pretend that the request is actually
coming from in this case Firefox I
believe so so you can provide the user
agent like like that and this is just a
little simple code to show that if if
you make the same request while spoofing
the header or not spoofing the header
you will get different results so in the
first one you will get whatever Python
library version you're using and the
second one you'll get exactly that piece
of text over there and and this is just
a simple website that if you open it it
tells you what is the user agent the
reason so what is the browser you're
using now finally I think this is my
final slide yes so this is how you
actually do all of this so if you have
this URL that you obtained let's imagine
from Twitter you want to pretend to be
Firefox you're going to connect using
the request get method to that URL using
that header the final URL is basically
the URL after all the redirect which
you're going to need to X to extract the
signature and the user information and
the check-in information so just like we
did before
here I'm using beautifulsoup basically
to parse the HTML of the of the check-in
page that I'm getting and I'm and then
I'm extracting basically the screen name
of the user the venue information and
just printing a little message saying
okay this you this user checked into
this place and again you can find a tote
on beautiful dot pie and if you don't
have any questions specifically about
this I'm going to tag my colleague in
yes
went back to Twitter they changed yes
yes yes there are many many techniques
to do this I mean I'm very limited in
time so I didn't really go into them
he's gonna talk a little bit about that
you can look basically at you can try
and parse the location field location is
something you typed by hand so it can be
not too reliable but you can parse it
directly you can look exactly at what
they're saying what they're mentioning
Twitter will try to add some
geographical information if it can and
that's why when I showed you the things
that were matching New York it was
showing things even outside New York
because it's matching the location field
and try to say okay if the location
field is inside New York then maybe I
should show this as well so it Twitter's
on somehow some ways is trying to
compensate for those things which is
kind of like Foursquare trying to give
you privacy but not but allowing you to
share your things at the same time well
that you want privacy which is kind of
you know no beautifulsoup
I didn't really go into the details but
basically is what it does is it parses
HTML and or XML and it's not really a
dictionary but you can kind of treat it
as a dictionary in some cases but
there's a world understanding how
beautiful super world sees another whole
another world that I didn't really have
too much time to go in today but
basically if you replace that URL this
will parse it exactly and will give you
the information so you don't even don't
really need to understand soup too much
and without further ado Anastacio stew
thank you thank you so that's pretty
heavy so can you hear me at the back yes
no okay so hello everybody we'll
continue from where Bruno left so it's
nice to collect all this data but what
can we do with it right so we will cover
several analysis and mining aspects of
this J reference data so I'm based at
Lancaster University I'm an associate
professor there I had the pass from
Foursquare a couple of years back and I
I have to thank University of Cambridge
for sponsoring my talk for paying for my
trip here let us start so though this is
London it's yellow dot is a Foursquare
place and we saw a sample of them and
what we'll be studying in the first part
of the talk is essentially a network of
places so as users move between between
one place to the other we effectively
connect them and the way people have
been studying social networks studying
friendships between people for the last
ten years what we our message here is
can we switch our perspective to places
now that location-based services and the
sharing economy service like uber Airbnb
and so on arising and try to see what
this type of network can tell us and
where it can be useful of course this
data is not only about static
representation of places but we have a
notion of the category of places of red
here is arts and entertainment in in
Foursquare
a greener outdoors and the size of each
circle is proportional to the popularity
of it right so let me cover your last
question and show you a trick on how to
acquire check-in data
abundantly and publicly so if you go on
Twitter and search for soorma
calm this is the actual check-in app of
Foursquare you can see a number of live
live tweets with with checking
information so every tweet has a URL
that points then to the storm web site
where you can get information about the
place the category in the user that has
checked in there and the nice thing
about this is when you search Twitter by
specifying a string query then you get
effectively all the tweets that are
associated with it back at a given point
in time right so let's focus on practice
now so we'll be starting place networks
as we mentioned so have you gone github
and you download the place network live
directory there you will find the code
you can run the code through the
terminal by doing Python network
analysis dot pi the data is there so we
have two data sets one it's a network
connecting places a Foursquare Network
of places connecting by means of user
movements and then for every place we
have geo coordinates and the title of it
and the title for example this is a
conference venue for pi data will be
used to allow us to interpret some of
the observations we make on the network
right so this is a library which I hope
you have installed it's Network X it's
very easy to install by the way so if
you download it now you can just do
Python setup install and it will do the
job for you but effectively what it is
it's a library that contains a lot of
utility functions and methods for
modeling and analyzing networks so let
us start so to begin with we need to
load the nodes of the network in now in
our case the nodes are places so I have
included a file in the folder where we
have a list of Foursquare places there
approximately a sample of 2000 public
places in New York anonymize by
and what we can do is basically parse
this CSV file file and for every place
get latitude longitude information the
title and ID and then effectively store
this information in a dictionary that
will process next to model the network
right so I have included here
visualization so how do we define this
directed Network direct it means that
Annette says directionality information
included in it so a user might go from
the cinema to the hotel or to the
gambling place or from the disco to the
cinema or though that's not very common
but anyway in benefit we have a place
network right that we can use network X
to read it basically store it as a sort
of like variable and then we can start
calculating statistics about it right
yes so and we also have we impose an
8-hour threshold so to make sure we
don't have check into there you know
three months apart and we have consent
so we have yeah we have applied the
filter with respect to time and
important information to extract from
for the network is basically how many
nodes there are there how many edges so
the order of the network and the size of
it and of course then we can print this
information and we can see how many
nodes we have in the network so if
anybody has run it maybe they can tell
how many you got that's a good one that
sound that sounds approximately what
what I had there and then the average
degree is sort of like a very sort of
like it's a representation of you know
picking a random node in the network
what would be the expected sort of like
number of edges that it has right how
well connected it is however we will say
that this is not a good
summation of what you see empirically in
the axial network because taking average
in this sort of like context doesn't
work so well so I will talk about this
in a bit and actually we will move with
a degree distribution of the network so
we take a node you know this and we want
to see what this distribution looks
across the network it's not distance its
connectivity so if I'm this venue and
you know I have five connections to
other venues then this is the degree of
of the venue and it's a very fundamental
concept in network analysis basically
tells you how important node isn't a
network direct paths yeah not service
certain spots is it different nodes in
the network so it can include multiple
hops from one node to the other whereas
here for example if you have 10 friends
on Facebook I'm really sorry about you
but but then when your degree is is 10
if you have a thousand then your degree
is 1000 yeah and that's what we are
after here and of course we have in
degree so outgoing edges and out out
degree in degree so edges a point to the
node and of course we can use Python to
read this information operating on the
network object returned by Network X and
then we can use matplotlib in order to
plot this degree distribution and we
will see that we will we will use two
scales the logarithmic scale so if you
set this variable log scale equal to
true then things will be plugged in look
at this scale if not then things will
look like that so that connects to the
previous point or why you shouldn't be
taking just the average degree in the
network because
most of the values in the system in the
network system are small so most places
here very small degree and occasionally
here place like Penn Station and so on
that would be having a very high degree
and for this type of very broad
distributions it's better to sell things
in logarithmic scale so you can see you
know how the same data in log log looks
much better in quotes and of course you
can operate on these curves and try to
characterize them mathematically
according to the slope this tip is a
slope the most important it's more
likely that you will get a node with
small degree right another important
important concept in network analysis is
the sort of like triadic closure so in
the context of social networks that
translates to a friend of my a friend of
my friend is also my friend so we tend
to form triangles and our question here
is do this place network systems also
show up this important property which we
can refer to as clustering coefficient
so you can you can run this code
basically after converting your network
to undirected for simplicity so we
disregard the directionality of the
edges then we can extract the connected
components those so looking at network
data basically you can have a set of
nodes a set of places being connected
but sometimes you can have like isolated
pairs of nodes being connected that I've
not connected to the bigger network so
we can apply this connect the component
subgraphs operation using network X and
get those components that are connected
with each other so all nodes connect
with one another in the network and we
will take the the first component by
using the zero index here and that is
called the giant component of the
network so this is the biggest component
where all pairs of nodes are connected
with each other
either directly or through hop by both
by hope connectivity so it has anybody
run this to report clustering
coefficient here yeah so basically if if
you have a node in the network is
connected to other nodes then those are
the nodes can be connected to each other
or not so in the case that they are
disconnected so you're like a form a
sort of like star connectivity then
clustering is zero we have no clustering
there's no community there right but
then when if they're connected with each
other then this goes up and this is
something that we observe in social
networks and we also observe actually in
place networks and it's an interesting
sort of like reflection of you know
where we socialize and you know where we
go basically now if you take the average
clustering coefficient you have to go
through every node in the network
measure for each the number of triangle
that you observe versus the number of
potential triangles and then get the
average across the network right and
what you should get here is something
like point two with a maximum bingquan
and the minimum being zero yes exactly
and it's this sort of like the building
block for studying communities or
clusters in these networks right
everything clear so far Abed not but
feel free to interrupt oh yes I don't
know you can code it and let us know
right I have to move a bit fast right so
we talked about degree distribution the
network so those metrics are known are
known as centrality met metrics and
networks so they give us an indication
of how important it's no these in that
particular time it case places right and
we have different type of centrality
methods and metrics so between a
centrality instead of looking at the
number of connections a place yes it
looks at the number of paths that
traverse that place
in the network so I might not have too
many connections but given to random
pairs of a random pair of nodes in the
network it might be the case that to go
from place one to place two I have to go
through place C and if the place is
found in a lot of cases in this context
then it has high betweenness centrality
so basically people have been trying to
devise different sort of like
formulations of centrality metrics and
try to see which of them would be more
appropriate for their particular
application scenario so we talked about
degree centrality and we will also look
at the eigenvector centrality
eigenvector centrality is an interesting
one because it tells you how well are
you connected to central nodes so you
might not have very high degree but you
might have a lot of interactions with
Penn Station that is very well connected
so that will raise your eigen vector
centrality just correlation matrix so so
the eigen values yeah that's a good
question so to be brief so you use the
adjacency matrix of the network you can
operate on that matrix and get the eigen
value distribution and then you apply a
mathematical formula there that can
allow you to extract the information I
described how well you're connected to
very central nodes so you're implicitly
central as well so you can use so what
we get from this sort of like centrality
operations here we get dictionaries
where it's node has an ID that is a key
of the dictionary and then the value is
the centrality of the node and of course
what we can do is use a utility method
get top dictionary keys were given a
dictionary and the number of the top K
most important nodes we won't Express
extract we can get them in that
particular case I'm applying the three
different centrality metrics with
parameter 10 so we'll get the 10 most
important nodes in New York and what
we'll do is like basically get the top
10 and we would plot the title of the
place so for its centrality metric we'll
try to see what is sort of like real
world place in New York that belongs to
the sort of like top 10 most connected
places right and this is the output so
you can see that airports tend to be at
the top of the list you can see that
there is a very high correlation at
least at the top 10 in terms of the
places that you find of those centrality
metrics but you have outliers as well
right so you can have cases of for
example the Central Park Park West that
which is the west side of Central Park
which the place in Foursquare appearing
the top 10 for degree centrality but has
low betweenness centrality so it doesn't
pair the top 10 and lower eigenvector
centrality as well so depending on the
application that you are going about
your going for you might want to use a
different central geometric everything
clear so far
yes yeah I think I think you can do it I
think you can basically apply different
methodologies so you can focus a
different sort of like subsets of nodes
in the network that you're interested in
of course these systems suffer from the
rich get richer effect where we have
like this very sort of like dominant set
of nodes that attract most of traffic
and so on but sometimes depending on
your applications now you might want to
focus in a small neighborhood and learn
something about it and of course you can
refine this matrix accordingly so if you
look online they're basically tens of
strongly metrics that have been proposed
and related to so the idea here is like
check the basics and maybe explore on
your own at your free time right so
Network X provides all the functionality
for drawing your graph it might not work
very well for graphs with a huge number
of nodes in the order of millions but in
the context of a city have usually
thousands of places or tens of thousands
which is which is a manageable size so
this is sort of like non geographic
representation in New York we we
basically store latitude and longitude
values at the position dictionary
position the dictionary is being passed
at the position parameter of the draw
function and then we can specify also
the size of the node on the graph and of
course we can store it and if you run
the code you can get this graph
basically and if you want to go more
sort of like beautiful and hardcore in
terms like visualization you use
processing and this is a snapshot made
by Foursquare designer we include it in
a paper
we study thoroughly this place networks
you can basically download it here and
look about their dynamics we do link
prediction so we we study how how the
network looks at a particular season of
the year and we try to predict how
connectivity will emerge in the next
period and so on so the goal here has
been to introduce these networks and
hopefully make the community more aware
about using them in real world
applications and talking about real
world applications we go to the second
part of the talk so with some friends in
Belgium we have been building open sweet
cub which is basically an application
that has been launched in New York we
have so far five thousand or more
registered users 1,000 active users and
basically can download it from the App
Store or the Google Play Store
if you if you want to to see how it
works the idea is you have origin and
destination that you're willing to
travel in the city and given that uber
has been introducing the very famous
surge pricing where pricing for a
particular journey depends on demand we
thought it would be really interesting
to compare prices with other companies
in that case it's been yellow taxis and
the way we have basically search results
for flights you have different companies
in different prices and you have
services on top of that we want to do
the same for taxi transport and what
we've been doing is we've been looking
at trips in New York City and we we took
advantage of publicly available data
which I will point to about yellow cabs
and we exploit ubers API as well and for
a given trip we can ask how much you
charge how much you charge take the
difference and see in fact that yellow
cabs tend to be cheaper so users and
this for example of 604 643 43 queries
queries in Arab use save on average six
dollars per trip and
actively we can save thousands we don't
make money out of it yet so we were
lucky because when we launched the app
back in March we had a few tens of users
but when the legend the main man team
picked it up we had essentially hundreds
of users joining and a lot of them still
using the app we are launching in London
soon and I will get to more details
about that but let's get practical and
solve this sort of like very interesting
task with which I think it's very
topical right and the task we want to
solve and you might as well do it by
downloading the certs prediction folder
from the github repo is given an area
can we characterize it in terms of like
demand uber demand and give it a sort of
like predict a value about it that is a
sort of like min certs multiplier the
average sales price multiplier for this
particular area and moreover can we use
Foursquare data and yellow taxi data to
do this and in fact the interesting
thing and I will point to a paper
related to that is that if you try to
predict uber demand using Foursquare
data you get a correlation point for
Pearson correlation if you use yellow
text data data you get point four but if
you combine them in a supervised
learning model then you get the best of
both worlds and you you do very well and
get a sort of like Pearson correlation
of 0.8
those are how this is a figure showing
how the sets multipliers are disputing
the city most peripheral areas are
basically having a multiplier that is
one but as you move towards the center
of Manhattan then you have like higher
demand and you can have like sets values
you can even go to 1.5 on average so
Bert has a base fare but on average the
effective charts to the customer happens
to be higher yes
so this is for a particular period yes
so and we have aggregated so you know if
you take one particular area search will
change over time right but we have
aggregated simplify the prediction tasks
for you know a given period of three
months of taxi trips and then we query
the uber API and we'll get into that and
we take the average of search for a
particular area if there is no search
yes and this is this is one right so
more specific areas usually do not
search unless it's an airport or
whatever right so this sir I would skip
this bit and we will move to this
working directory and I shall introduce
aside from the taxi data which you can
find in in the github folder we use also
a B&B data and what you can do
essentially is basically you can get
this CSV file where we have a sample of
Airbnb listings in New York and store
this in in a Python list or the
coordinates and basically out of all the
data that is there you have multiple
fields about reviews how popular the
place is how many people have been there
and so on we take just latitude and
longitude because all we want to do is
see if we can use how frequent Airbnb is
encountered
how frequently it's being encountered as
an area how frequently our taxi trips at
an area how frequently a Foursquare
place at an area and combine those to
predict search you can download a lot of
Airbnb data following that website not
only about New York so you can look at
different cities around the world you
this is a very interesting data set uber
has an API which you can query to get
price information so this is an example
of a request that is the request dot PI
file in the folder where you can find
this math
so given a larger than a longitude of
the origin of the trip and then latitude
and longitude of the destination we
basically ask what is the price that you
would charge thee to put specific point
in time we get the price back and then
basically this is getting to your
question essentially here what I plot is
basically for different types of fruits
we have like a devolution of asserts
MIDI multipliers so for a specific route
we have like the price changing over
time and what we do is take the average
of this and then we aggregate over all
routes at specific area you can query
the API now but we won't collect the
data now that's why I have included this
old in the past and calculated in the
past we did it like three months ago you
can query yeah yeah but you will get the
price now yeah yeah it would be nice if
it was like that no all right and we
here is a I think it should move a bit
more quickly right so here we have ten
minutes and I have seven slides it's not
bad actually
so basically of course we want to split
the city in two areas and bring us out
before you know how we can get different
sort of like border delineations within
New York here we'll use just a grid so
you can apply a simple grid structure on
top of the city and then effectively
what we want to do for its layer of data
that we use we want to calculate the
number of occurrences and then see if
this can predict this the deserts
potential of an area so here we
initialize the New York
sort of like grid that's how you can
call it we have a maximum and minimum
longitude we have a step which specifies
the size of the cell you can have bigger
smaller grid cells
and then we have three numpy arrays to
dimensional arrays where we measure the
number of Foursquare venue currencies
Airbnb listings and number of taxi trips
here is the code that you know if you
run it you will get how many of its we
have in the data and this is how how it
looks basically so what we do here is we
iterate for the three different layers
of data we have the geographic
coordinates of its layer we take the
latitude and longitude for its pair of
coordinates we take if the coordinates
are within the grid if they're outside
we can just discard them and then given
a latitude and longitude we want to find
where where it fits in the grid right so
we want to find this cell where the data
actually belongs to and basically we can
augment the number of currencies per
cell for its of the data layers we have
by iterating through these three data
layers right so here I'm getting to how
do we plot the distribution of Sert's
values right area so if you run this you
will get this graph so basically we
assumed we have crawled over API we use
this average search in cell CSV file to
get for every area the average cell
coefficient multiply it and then what we
do effectively we use a pattern at
histogram to plot all the cell's values
and this is what it looks like and now
what we can do is basically go through
every layer that we've stored in our
grid structure and ask to what extent
the frequency of occurrences survives
for a certain layer
matches the sort of like this size of
the certs
value so to what extent the different
layers correlate with uber demand
effectively so if you get the data for
yellow taxis you can see that the person
our correlation is point 43 for
Foursquare places is point four of
course an important thing to take into
account here is we have use a sample of
both and the sample matters here the
goal is to show you the methodology when
you will get different data sets from
your sources you might get different
numbers here Airbnb listings despite the
fact that we have more listings for
example in Foursquare places the
correlation is lower but the goal is how
can we combine these two supervised
learning model and maximize our
prediction scores these are actually
correlation measurements they're not
predictions but effectively correlations
the first step towards prediction task
right ok so how do we do supervised
learning in Python we use scikit-learn
of course it's one of our favorites and
to begin with basically what we do is we
want to initialize our training set in
terms of like features and labels so we
iterate through the set of areas for its
area we have a set value this is the
label this is the sort of like goal of
our prediction and then in the training
set we store the three layers of
information yellow taxi trips number of
Airbnb listings and number of Foursquare
places and then effectively we do
testing and testing is really important
in machine learning you don't want to
over fit right there was a discussion
the machine learning panel yesterday
about what what's the best testing
methodology one of the the one that I
think is more appropriate to use is
leave one out error and this is known as
an unbiased estimator of the general
error in a prediction task where
effectively what you do is you have a
training set you pick one point you take
it out and you make it your testing
point you train the model to the rest of
the data and then you try to predict
basically the point that you took out
and then you iterate for all points in
your data set and this is the sort of
like theoretically the best estimation
you can have in a prediction task of for
the generalization error but it costs a
lot because you have to iterate through
all your points the data sitting you
know if you think you have to do that
and optimize your classifier for
billions of points that would take a lot
of time here we don't have this problem
the data is parts so we have like two
three thousand areas in New York then we
can do this pretty quickly so
effectively what we do that's that's the
implementation of this process here we
take we set up the training data the
label data we make sure that all certs
multipliers for of equal of value one
are removed so this is noise essentially
if you try to include areas that have
sets value on average one then you will
get too many of them with different
features and that will confuse a
classifier so if you want to get things
running properly you have to do a little
bit your training set and then
effectively you can train a decision
tree regressor
which is effectively a regression model
implemented as a tree we have set here
through some experimentation the depth
of the tree to be 30 there's a number of
sort of like branch switches we do the
fitting on the training data and then we
do the testing on the particular area
that we have left out and then we can
store our predictions and calculate the
correlation values and
I wonder if anybody has managed to run
this and tell me what is the correlation
they got nobody okay ha ha
so it's point 83 or something so whereas
what you get before is again is the same
thing is like point four point four and
point three for each of the different
information signals in your data when
you combine them you get something
better and effectively what does this
translate to this translates to the fact
that twist mate demanded an area you
have to look at basically different
users so maybe some of the uber users
are part of the Foursquare community
some of them are not Foursquare users
but they used to be or they are yellow
taxi users and then of course the two
services are rather the sharing economy
umbrella so one might as well exploit
Airbnb in this context tube that is it
um I would like to announce a new
version of open Street camp the app that
helps you find the cheapest taxi
provided in the city come in next month
we are also launching in London you can
find more information about where this
we discussed day on this paper
follow us on Twitter and thank you for
your time